A hallmark pattern of material design
is using a floating action button or
F-A-B, FAB.
This is a vibrant-colored
circular icon button
that floats above the rest
of your content in your app.
And it's a way of promoting
a prominent action and
of communicating
the character of a screen.
As this button floats in
front of other content,
it's always easily accessible and
communicates its importance.
While it floats above content, and
generally has the highest elevation of
all views, it can still respond to
changes in other parts of your UI.
For example, scrolling with
the content or repositioning.
FABs have standard sizes and
elevations, so
that they are recognizable
across applications.
They come in either 40 or
56dp diameters and
generally have a resting elevation
of 6dp, rising to 12dp when pressed.
While they can be positioned
where ever makes sense for
your interface,
they tend to sit well on seams and
steps where two surfaces meet or
anchored to an appropriate corner.
Just as the FAB is a great way to direct
attention, you should be careful not to
overuse it everywhere in your app,
and only use a single FAB per screen.
Not every screen needs a FAB, but if
there is one clear action on the screen
then it's a great way to promote it.
If you're struggling to identify
which action should be a FAB
then it's a good sign that you probably
don't need one on that screen.